ey Leute was geht ab und Herz willkommen
zu meinem diesjährigen zweiten
Adventskalender Unboxing das Gute ist
heute wir haben eine Assistentin Johanna
Johanna ist nicht meine Freundin Johanna
kenne ich schon ganz lange die ist
gerade bei mir und ich wollte unbedingt
gucken was da drinne deswegen kannst du
da gerne so stehenbleiben das habe ich
bestellt weil das hat mir jemand
zugeschickt und empfohlen dass ich den
noch mal zeigen soll auf jeden Fall
Leute hier haben wir den Puhdys Text njt
Adventskalender der war nicht so teuer
also ich glaube der hat 60 € kostet 59 €
wenn ich euch hier mal ein und da sollen
Süßigkeiten aus aller Welt drin sein was
für mich mega spannend ist ja früher
super auf Videos gemacht wo ich so Boxen
bestellt habe da waren ein Süßigkeiten
aus Brasilien aus Afrika aus Amerika
drin und wir Merzen Adventskalender mit
Süßigkeiten aus aller Welt das ist doch
eine geile Sache deswegen habe ich den
auch bestellt und dachte mir ich stelle
euch mal vor oder wir machen halt ein
kleines lustiges Unboxing dazu wenn ihr
den letzten Adventskalender noch nicht
gesehen habt dann check das auch gerne
ab der war nicht so gut sei ich mal
wobei da muss ich mich korrigieren gut
verpackt hier
genau da muss ich noch mal was zu sagen
diese Creme im ersten Türchen die kostet
fast 100 € das wusste ich nicht somit
ist das schon kein mega schlechter
Kalender gewesen also es war trotzdem
nicht die 300 € wieder angepriesen waren
aber mein Resümee war dann doch ein
bisschen schlechter als es eigentlich
hätte ausfallen deswegen sorry an dieser
Stelle wollte ich mal kurz gesagt haben
hier haben wir jetzt 123 ja wieder 24
Kästchen werde es gedacht man muss ja
sagen, ich glaube es gibt irgendwie so
eine Firma die machen ganz ganz viele
von diesen individuell gestaltbaren
Adventskalender die sehen an sicher
komplett gleich aus nur das Design ist
mal ein bisschen anders ne und
vielleicht auf die Türchen Verteilung
nur weil ich mir da gar nicht so sicher
bin der Letzte Adventskalender sah
einfach genauso aus naja warum man nicht
lange labern und mach mal die eins auf
die unten oder schon du willst auch
ausprobieren bringen bisher noch hier
oder, hier ist fast Nummer 50 ist
nur Spaß Leute dann machen wir mal hier
die eins auf guck mal das finde ich
schonmal gut wir haben hier tatsächlich
Bio Mandeln ja ich denke schon dass das
gebrannte Mandeln sind warte kann ich
dir gleich sagen
wie willst du das ist natürlich nur sehr
wenig aber aufm Weihnachtsmarkt und so
Band Mannheim Kosten immer nur 4 € oder
350 ne als wegen als Einstieg finde ich
das super danke dafür ist auch was man
sie nicht zuviele erschweren wir noch 53
und so ja mal die zwei ich verlinke euch
den Kalender natürlich der Viehbestand
das habe ich damals bei ihm nie
vergessen sag was haben wir hier ach so
hätte ich dich jetzt nicht hier da wird
mir sowas wahrscheinlich gar nicht
auffallen, Leute hier stehen überall so
Sachen drauf hin gemütliches feeling
über Lichterketten aufhängen hier steht
drauf Mini Rezept heiße Schokolade für
kalte Tage von Rezept ist auch noch mit
dabei achso aus welchem Land kommen
Mandeln Deutschland oder da sind ja halt
ganz viele verschiedene Länder mit
vertreten mit ganz vielen verschiedenen
weihnachtlichen essence heuchen ja
vielleicht in Italien werden anscheinend
ahrlini ganz viel gegessen was auch
immer das sein mag aber deswegen sind
wir ja hier um zu probieren. Mal das
sind so Chips von bisschen weg
Käsestangen locker die Nummer drei Manke
Coldewey Lieschen handgefertigt aus
Mandeln
Lebkuchenteig ich muss mal kurz was an
meine Nummer sagen und zwar früher hatte
ich immer einen Schoko Kalender und es
war immer mein Traum ihren ganzen
kalender an einem Tag aufs Essen jetzt
sitze ich hier habe mir diesen Kalender
gekauft für 60 € und es sind einfach an
einem Tag komplett auf ist mir
scheißegal wolfsgut sagen weil ich habe
immer Ärger bekommen wenn ich den ganzen
kalender an einem Tag gegessen habe
gucke jetzt haben wir die ho ho ho die
Nummer 49 ich hoffe ihr könnt das lesen
das ist Allegro Nougat wenn er nicht
alles aufessen ist ja unmöglich war
super lecker Gehörgang hier die fünf die
fünf ist groß der Big Five das ist aber
ziemlich leid ich glaube das sind Kitze
was haben wir hier war ja Snack never
Fried ich muss mal kurz was loswerden
und zwar habe ich gedacht wie wird der
angepriesen mit 24 internationalen
Snacks wie Chips diversen
schokoladengebäck und so weiter
Fruchtgummis Pipapo dass das dann z.b.
auch wirklich Süßigkeiten aus aller Welt
sind und nicht alles so aus Deutschland
kommen weil normalerweise könnte dann ja
auch mal was auf Spanisch drauf stehen
oder englisch also international ist das
anderes bist jetzt vielleicht kommt das
ja Nachos oder schmecken wenn du gesund
bist Frage was ist denn am 6.1 Nikolaus
genau weil du es erraten hast darfst du
das auch machen und was haben wir was am
anderen das sieht aber gut aus Roth
Leute das hier waren dann noch mal sechs
ich weiß trotzdem mal rein wo kommt
sowas her ist ja auch nicht
Internationalist wird euch bestimmt
also geschmacklich besser als gedacht
und wir
fahren zusammen
meistern sind irgendwelche
[Musik]
ja und dann hat man hier auch so ein
Muster drauf mit karamellisierten Nüssen
ein Kollege hier lass es dir schmecken
und dann haben wir hier noch die Nummer
10 Wasabi Erdnüsse kann das nicht essen
glaube ich hasse war Sabine dass sie gar
nichts für mich und noch ganz wichtig es
ist in Honig Beton steht da wenn man
schmeckt auch mehr den Honig als Wasabi
weil schmeckt doch gut hätte ich nicht
gedacht so weitergeht für 11-12 L12 hier
haben wir varosi salt Caramel
Marshmallow made in Belgium jetzt noch
cooler gefunden wenn das international
wäre so dass man auch mal was aus
Amerika bisschen was aus Australien
hätte aber wir haben anscheinend bis
jetzt nur Europa ist auch ok in möchte
ich eigentlich nicht aufmachen weil das
wird mir nachher gleich schlecht weiter
geht's mit der Nummer 12 extend JSON wie
ein Cookie vegan Cookie from middle
Germany
13/14 aufpassen so ich mache dann die
die 14 auf ja da sitzt man noch gut oder
sie haben wir TK tannis great taste of t
oder wenn man wissen was ja
also hier auf jeden Fall über Schiffe
catanies Symbole ganz wild was ist die
Nummer 14 ach das war wieder für dich
was ne Schokolade auf die nächst geil
die hatten gerade schon so ähnlich
chocolate chip Cookie Dough so sieht das
aus Leute nicht eigentlich auch ganz
neues da muss ich mal ein Stückchen
probieren Alter super habt ihr schonmal
so eine Schokolade gesehen sieht ein
bisschen aus wie viel gewinnt ne
drei nebeneinander gelegt hat drei
gewinnt möchte auch eins aber ich will
auch so ein Fan davon von so ein
bisschen süß du das
lied das gerade bei mir nicht das ist zu
viel verschiedenes durcheinander
Proteinriegel was ist ein
Protein Riegel
Irland
ich kann nicht mehr jetzt schon Granola
Powersnack King Monkey muss ich auch
sagen Ansicht cooles Design was ist denn
das für probier's einfach mal
kommt auch aus Belgien das ist auch ganz
Schokolade und Banane schmeckt das nicht
so ganz bisschen
was meinst du denn da 24 dann haben wir
hier jetzt noch die
22 übernehmen die nächste Schokolade
mehr als nur lecker mit Cranberries und
da muss man
die verkaufen diese Schokolade genießen
Sie und teilen Sie und dann werden
gebaut
London
kosten aber schmeckt auch ganz gut Nüsse
mit Chili und Ahornsirup mir du kannst
auf die 23 aufmachen und ich mache mich
dann jetzt schon mal an die 24 sind
Mandeln ok bin ich langweilig ich möchte
jetzt die 24 und wir machen dramatische
Musik reinziehen links und ziehen reich
und machen die Garage auf
dudududududu
Christmas Biskuit, die sind alle einzeln
eingepackt die sind für mich so aus wie
halt diese Dinger die man im Café zum
Kaffee dazu bekommt man die
wahrscheinlich oder wo kommen die her ja
ich glaube die kommen aus England
24. ich muss sagen bin ich ganz
zufrieden mit dem Kalender 60 € hier für
jedes Teil im Schnitt also 2 € wir haben
aber auch noch die ganzen Rezepte mit
drauf die Weihnachts Checkliste das
ganze Design eigentlich ganz cool
deswegen finde ich ist der Preis
angebracht also da macht man auf jeden
Fall nichts und falsch cooler Kalender
mehr Spaß gemacht beim Auspacken mir ist
ein bisschen schlecht weil ich habe
jetzt glaube ich in der letzten halben
Stunde so 20 verschiedene Süßigkeiten
probiert und halt auch keine Süßigkeiten
zwei Leute schickt mir super gerne noch
weitere Kalender die ich bestellen soll
weil es geht ja auch schon los mit dem
ersten klöppchen haben wir schon den 1.
Dezember
an johanna dass du mich so tatkräftig
unterstützt hast